okay so doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness looks like it's going to be
more exciting than finding out your
variant is hot and it's technically not
incest
okay so doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness looks like it's going to be
more exciting than a party that no one
remembers at comitage the latest
trailers and tv sports are laced with a
lot of details and wtf moments that make
it seem like it's going to capitalize on
the reality-breaking storyline set up by
no way home there's tons of rumors
reports and potential plot leaks on the
film that seem to line up with the
trailers and throughout this video we're
gonna be going through it in what we
think is chronological order this is
purely guesswork after watching the
trailer on repeat like it's a day with
dormammu but you know we have to put a
spoiler warning in this might
potentially ruin the movie for you but
if you have a memory as bad as i do then
you'll probably forget all this before
strange even has a chance to do a
forgetting spell be it at your parallel
and if you enjoyed the video then make
sure you hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe without the
way huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the breakdown okay so
going off the teasers and what we've
reported on the movie the film will open
with defender strange america chavez and
a variant of wong at the center of the
multiverse not to get too far ahead of
ourselves but you might notice that when
america is held in the air there's a
pillar beside here and this later
appears when strange chavez and
christine open up the hatch i'm not sure
what's on the glowing pillar in the
middle but this looks like it's a book
stand so potentially it's something to
combat the darkhold now this scene was
heavily shown in the super bowl tv spot
and the group get attacked by a giant
red ribbon like monster who we think
might kill defender strange it looks
like the monster will string america up
as she tries to open a portal behind her
and this is when defender strange will
step in he will fling her through the
portal and get stuck on the outside of
it which is when he's killed we get a
shot of him spinning through the air and
if you slow it down and look at his face
then you'll notice there are distinct
scars across it jump to the end of the
tv spot when we see the undead version
and it not only has the same ponytail as
defender strange but the scars are there
too i'm guessing that his death is what
wakes up the mcu doctor strange who we
see shoot up from his bed he talks about
how the nightmare is always the same and
according to leaks on the film there'll
be lots of versions of him getting
killed throughout the multiverse that
the mcu timeline will have visions up we
then likely see his reflection in the
smashed watch that christine gave him at
the start of his solo movie this carries
a lot of important iconography with it
as he of course broke time in that film
which was reflected in the face of the
lovely gift however the movie is about
breaking the multiverse open and
therefore i'm guessing that the watch
here reflects reality being cracked up
the multiverse being shown in fractured
glass is something that not only appears
in the tv spot with wonder but it also
shows up on the poster too so yeah i'm
going with that one guys and if you
don't like it there's no dislike button
now so shut the hell up see you chump
and moving on i think that christine's
wedding will be the big thing that
strange has to do that day strange got
snapped away i think in this time she
will have found someone else i'm hoping
so anyway as it would be a bit quick of
her if she got snapped too and then came
back and arranged a wedding with some
bloke in the space of six months saying
that though maybe she didn't have time
for doctor strange a watch joke see now
we catch them rushing out of the
ceremony in the second trailer and it
seems that this is when gorganzo's
attacks it looks like it's going after
america and stranger wong both have to
step in to stop it strange cuts a bus in
half which yeah like the one in eternals
luckily no one is riding it now my guess
is that at this point he finds out about
the multiverse being broken open from
america and seeks out the only person
capable of handling things a crazy woman
crazy crazy woman that enslaved an
entire town so she could pretend that
she was living in a sitcom she's someone
you could trust it's not gonna go badly
now it seems like it catches up to her
pretty fast and the character has likely
been keeping an eye on her for quite a
bit if you cast your mind back to thor
ragnarok you'll remember he almost
instantly captured loki when he arrived
on midgard strange told thor that he
keeps an eye on tourettes and he's
probably allowed her to go off and make
her garden because she's a [ __ ]
nutcase and will just go mental if you
try and talk to her for more than five
minutes about not [ __ ] robots more
than lando calrissian now interestingly
this scene seems like it's an illusion
and the entire garden is probably fake
if you pay close attention to strangers
clothes during this then you'll see that
the same as they are later on when we're
in the chaos dimension with the two
characters therefore i think we should
place these scenes as being one in the
same and that it all kicks off when
strange goes to her it's difficult to
guess what's going on but i would
imagine it's tied to the darkhold and
potentially he finds out she's been
messing with reality in order to get her
kids back this is when it all kicks off
and they fight across the multiverse
interestingly when strange first arrives
at a garden she's pruning branches which
is terminology that was used in loki to
describe wiping out a timeline she's
likely a major multiversal threat and
we'll get into this in just a bit now
america chavez can open portals across
the multiverse and according to the
leaks wandao will want to get this power
for herself so she can be with the kids
once more this will likely be where the
big action scene at comitage happens in
which a big cloud of smoke rolls in by
the looks of this this is probably
wonder who's launching an assault on the
wizards in order to get america if you
pay close attention to the trailers then
you might notice that wong is held up in
the air at some point and on his wrists
is the red glowing chaos magic that's
synonymous with the skull at which i'm
guessing that wong is captured by that
american strange escape which is when we
see them traveling through several
planes of reality it looks like one may
be a world in which the dinosaurs
weren't wiped out but this could also be
the savage land which is basically the
land that time forgot either way they
seem to end up in the ultron bot reality
which wonder will no doubt be coming to
so she can get herself a new man
oh [ __ ]
here we go again look at them walking in
like some weird episode of take me out
now it appears that this is the one in
which defender strange was the guardian
of as we see a statue dedicated to him
perhaps at the start of the movie he was
taking america to get whatever was on
that pedestal and that's why strange
chavez and christine go there later now
this is a massive guess but it seems
like it's here where strange comes
across a variant of mordo who sort of
fills in what's happened in this reality
shortly after he's captured and taken
before the illuminati which moro seems
to be a member of if you zoom into the
top and look at the guy walking across
it appears a lot like mordo and later on
the pair fight in this room with strange
wearing the handcuffs now it's difficult
to tell who's on the council as it's
very badly lit should be having words
with the set director there but we know
that professor x is at least a member
they don't even show professor x's face
just a shot of his shoulder what bad
directing that is now the other ones
look like what i believe is captain
carter and she was reported to be
popping up in the movie after her first
what if episode there's also a person
that looks like they're either mr
fantastic a version of black panther or
someone completely different i'm
guessing that during this time america
is taken in two and this is why we see
the shot in the trailer where she's in a
prison a variant of christina's there
and she later appears to join strange in
america as they travel into the reality
from the opening wonder appears to
attack and she goes up against captain
marvel maria rambo slash iron lad slash
superior iron man or whoever it is that
the internet thinks it is this week try
telling them who i think it is but no
one listens so whoever you think it is
that's who it is now i'm guessing that
she goes up against you i don't know why
you guys watch these videos all i do is
insult you but you know i love you guys
i'm just just playing with you we're
best mates in a way are we now i'm
guessing that she goes up against the
entire illuminati and during this
strange uses it as an opportunity to
escape
he probably grabs america and christine
and we even see wonder with blood all
over her face might be oil oh i've seen
some people say it's oil and we all know
she likes to get a robot shooting oil
all over her face but moving on she
appears to turn into a zombie at this
point possibly showing that she's
becoming more corrupted if you cast your
mind back to one division you might
remember that as agatha drained her she
started to look like the undead so
something along those lines could also
be happening here now at this point i'm
guessing that christine america and
strange go to the weird pedestal thing
and that the next port of call is the
destroyed looking new york this is very
similar to what happened in what if when
strange supreme ended up destroying
reality in order to try and alter a
fixed point in time the top of the
buildings look black and gooey and the
streets of nyc seem completely empty
there's no one shouting hey i'm walking
here and everything is abandoned i hope
no one from new york's watching this now
at the heart of this seems to be the
sanctum sanctuarium which also has the
weird black inky goo thing at the top of
the building inside strange finds a
version of himself who basically talks
about the podiatre and what happened
after he drank 20 sambucas and tried to
[ __ ] the mine at all things just got out
of hand
now there's a point where strange seems
to be practicing chaos magic with a buck
on the floor around him appears to be
the sinister sanctuarium so i'm guessing
that this is the same location as where
he finds the villainous variant at this
point we will likely either get wonder
fighting a version of herself in the
multiverse or we just go straight into
the last battle this involves what i
believe is defender strange the energies
of the darkhold america fighting wonder
and potentially steven going against
himself i don't think there's anything
beyond that point except maybe that
weird little crow shot but by the looks
of it that's every shot from the trailer
mapped out based on what we've heard and
of course love to hear your thoughts and
on screen right now we have a couple of
videos discussing lots of things about
the marvel universe hopefully you have a
brilliant day and you've you've had a
laugh
we've had a bit of a laugh i'll see you
on the next one you take care of
yourself peace